from eleven years old he stuff with
anorexia and then she was born to
antidepressants fluoxetine and about 12
years old from 13 she started
self-harming in their first three so I
10 was shortly after that she first went
to Seven Oaks in Kent then via
Southampton Woking Hawkinson Manchester
Norwich yeah no he's about soon 58 miles
more my journey and we did that should
have about seven months and the final
place when she was it in a car machine
it was in there was in Northampton and
that she's been eighteen months there
okay how is she she's went to model unit
in the local town May last year and
looking back at her self-harm over the
years nothing's changed we've had
13-hour dosed in the last seven months
and self-harm has got got quite critical
at the moment she's at college now she's
doing military were like that but this
her still her fears are still there
nothing's changed really and I think
even private companies that run these
monies units do not prepare the local
services either for this because when
you get her to level services there's
nothing there for you either
so what support did she receive during
that what five years that she's been
receiving well the support we had really
because when your child relapses has a
moment with the mental health issues
they takes ages to get in a second and
then you did then you can wait anything
up to two weeks for a bed and we
obviously we but look we weren't too
fussed about the distance where she
traveled as long as as long as she's
getting the right treatments the problem
we had is that everywhere she went it
was a bed in the UK and you get there
and and they vary from from bad to and
that's been good really because this
places where she's been where they've
run out of medication where she hasn't
released properly instant happened
overnight and we get a telephone and
when what's happened you get no
information about about your child when
you dropped them off at the hospital you
don't see the bedroom it's like you've
put him for an airlock door and that's
all you see you got to ask for
permission to go and see the bedrooms
and this is a needs that people looking
after your daughter I mean the vast
majority of staff the problem with them
is they're underpaid and we've noticed
over the years that they do use a lot of
agency staff and I can't see how that's
Farsi viable because with mental health
issues the pages need to build a trust
with members of staff to actually making
themselves better and because people
change too often they didn't ever get
that I don't
his patch over the crux really they said
yeah she's okay now she'd go about the
community and then usually within
probably 12 to 14 weeks we're doing
exactly the same thing again the long
she spent her home with seven months
between between units and that was a
nightmare because she's so it so power
about being hurt by somebody or hurt by
something
she spent all the time in bed with a mum
and why slept in her room and that we
did that for seven months because we
just want to stay at home we knew she's
going downhill but we tried and tried
and tried to keep her home and because
local services so bad
we just inevitable happened and she went
back into unit again in what way do you
feel that these units numerous units
have failed your daughter they failed
because I don't I don't think they
actually take on board how because when
you pass your response begin to want
onto that Ponton people they're
basically her parents and they don't I
don't think they treat them with respect
they deserve Jessica stole his stuff
that's happened with him was about
restraints and stuff like that but we
kind of phone them up and say right
because we got over the years she can
tell little white lies and try one
against the other but there's always
some truth there somewhere
and what do you mention it all you get
from these people is all yeah she's
she's she's second on the mental health
she's probably lying anyway and you try
and get information and because she's
got more power than we have his parents
gonna under the medal of how fat she
could dictate what we can and can't know
for example their last placement in
Northampton we knew she was ligature in
because we she see on Sunday very really
got a phone call on the Monday but
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday make a phone
call we knew someone happened and then
we get a phone call on Thursday I need
bra pants trousers because she's lose
all these aren't the clothes ligatures
what would you say to the health
secretary if he was watching I think
need to wake up because I think not just
letting my daughter down they letting a
lot of a lot of children down because
it's bizarre that he spent five or six
years out of area when she was from
thirteen to eighteen because I think the
way it works and it just England pay if
you're under eighteen for for your stay
in its secure unit I think then
transfers to your local authority want
you to an eighteen and they couldn't
wait to get back to Somerset I think the
system is broken yeah how many more
children and they gonna let die before
something's done